l'ex doit à nouveau on est arrivé c'est
quoi ce temps dehors tu t'appelles
comment je me souviens de rien qui nous
a envoyés ici on sait pas qu'est ce
qu'il ya derrière
le labyrinthe
tous les matins quand les portes
s'ouvrent les coureurs cherchent une
sortie
personne n'a survécu une seule nuit dans
le labyrinthe
qu'est ce qui leur arrive
on n'a rien à faire ici
c'est le moment savoir contre qui on
doit se battre
tout a changé dès l'instant où cas
arriver
c'est une fille
non
pourquoi on est différent tel qu'on nous
a envoyés pour une raison précise
tu n'es pas comme les autres tu es
curieux
tu veux rester ici
il va falloir m'assurer que tu va
respecter les règles